m night shyamalan's old follows a group
of families trapped on a private beach
that causes them to age very quickly
essentially making a lifetime pass by in
a single day
old is full of big ideas and baffling
concepts
so naturally viewers are going to have
some questions
in the film's final act it's revealed
that every one of the beach's
inhabitants is an unwilling participant
in a medical trial study
the resort is a front for an
organization testing experimental new
drugs on hand-picked subjects
since the island's natural energies
cause people to age so rapidly
they can conduct years of study within
an afternoon
when all the subjects for this
particular trial have died one of the
scientists
sydney explains that the tragedy wasn't
all for naught
as their new epilepsy drug worked on
patricia preventing her seizures for 16
years in beach time but when patricia
dies in the second act it's from a
series of violent seizures that take her
life
now every other death on the beach that
isn't self-inflicted or
literal murder is either an accident or
the ravages of aging
essentially natural causes but patricia
isn't shown to have aged fast enough to
die of old age
the way guy and prisca eventually go out
after roughly a half hour of screen time
without a seizure she succumbs to a
series of them in short
order and dies but if the new drug was
such a success how did a seizure still
kill her
what happened to her it's entirely
likely that the scientists behind this
project
just have lower barriers for success
relative to their murky moral barometers
than the average viewer might
their final act celebration certainly
sounded rousing enough to suggest the
drug would prevent someone from dying
from seizures much less having them at
all
if the simple answer to how she died is
that the medication works well but just
not that well
it really means these folks are
compartmentalizing and patting
themselves on the back even more than
initially thought
one of the other weird things that
happens on the beach is that each of the
trial subjects has seeming
invulnerability
until they don't so when charles slashes
at rapper mid-sized sedan with a knife
his face cuts heal immediately but when
he stabs him repeatedly in the vital
organs he dies but the quick healing
stuff gets pretty confusing when prisca
must defend charles from murdering her
husband guy
the same way he ultimately did sedan she
fends him off with a rusty knife and
when it pierces his skin
charles's entire body begins to
transform like a particularly involved
fatality from mortal kombat
as she matter effectively explains that
the rust on the knife is like poison in
the human bloodstream
that actor vicky creeps delivers this
dialogue with an absolute straight face
is borderline astonishing because no
matter how crazy old gets
that's a far from satisfactory
explanation for the cartoon death
charles undergoes
we're willing to chuck this one up to
well this doesn't make a lot of sense
but it sure does look pretty cool
in the film's final series of
revelations the resort manager talks to
a staff about how nature gave them this
beach anomaly and all the supernatural
effects it brings
suggesting nature itself wanted this
place found and exploited through
man-made means to help heal the sick
it's a stirring supposition to rally a
team around
especially if you need to on a daily
basis help them make peace with killing
innocent people in the pursuit of
medical breakthroughs
but how exactly is the beach you know
like that
who found it how long did it take them
to tap into their capitalistic instincts
to turn it into a murder farm for big
pharma
obviously the experiments themselves
took a lot of trial and error
but how much trial and error happened in
this region accidentally from people
freaking out and turning geriatric
before sundown before some enterprising
person came along and was like hey let's
use this naturally occurring hellscape
to sell better drugs
honestly the core origins of the island
and the beach itself could branch off
into 30 or 40 more unanswered questions
but there's really only one more that
cannot be ignored
trying to reverse engineer the complete
history of the beach and its origins is
a fool's errand or
more likely the problem of whoever
shyamalan tasks with expanding the
mythology into some kind of
direct-to-streaming prequel miniseries
in the event old does numbers at the box
office but there's a more pressing
question the viewer is left with at the
end of
old while maddox and trent are on their
way home from exposing the resort's true
nature
if the resort manager isn't blatantly
lying and his fervor suggests at the
very least he believes in what they're
doing
that means that even though
theoretically a thousand or so people
have died over these 73 trial groups
the findings from the study have served
to save thousands more
perhaps millions so if what they were
doing was unsavory but
necessary work were maddox and trent in
the right for exposing them
but that question raises a bigger
question is all the rhetoric the manager
and his colleagues spew at one another
legit
and this is a purely humanitarian
enterprise designed to help the world
despite having to let tons of people die
to do so
or is that just the company line they
all tell themselves to sleep at night
and this resort is just a more science
fiction take on the kind of exploitative
work
all major corporations require in order
to provide ample value for their
shareholders if it's the former then
maybe maddox and trent were justified
especially considering
they have now lost half their lifespans
not to mention their own parents
this place clearly needs more oversight
but given how well they were able to
operate without interference from law
enforcement
suggests that whoever founded this
operation also had the grease to keep
them shrouded from regulatory agencies
and
other powerful organizations that should
have put a stop to this
far sooner check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the latest summer
blockbusters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one